[Music]
[Music]
13 o clock hey everybody happy
Valentine's Day yeah Valentine's Day
show this was gonna be very upsetting
yeah I love you hate valentines day
the show for you yeah I know I've been
here about this case my whole adult life
this [ __ ] here terrible
where are two cases and they're both
equally terrible I was think about the
one from England first they're both her
English they both amendment yeah the one
where they recorded that girl yeah
that's when I was thinking about Brady
and him yeah Brady and him we're also
doing Fred and rosemary West yeah yeah
yeah well the reason okay so like the
reason that I did this if you guys
remember on our Valentine's Day special
last year we did killer couples and I
think we did like four or five different
ones and that was like it's super
popular show and it was like kind of fun
to do and I kind of [ __ ] up way and I
said well I've been wanting to do a show
on either Fred and rosemary West for
Myra Hindley and Ian Brady for like a
really long time and I said well let's
do killer couples UK edition yeah I
thought to do and so we'll just talk
about both of that I thought today was
just gonna be hidden Liam Brady but I
know the other one to that other ones
bad yeah yeah this is Alexis I've seen a
lot of stuff on that although Hindley
and Liam Brady I read a book about them
long I did - oh yeah yeah and then I can
remember some programs that they played
here here in the United States back in
the early 80s and they actually played
excerpts from those damn torture tapes
that they were doing on that little girl
yeah and I don't know how they got away
with it back then just people were hard
more hardcore but man I heard those
recordings man that [ __ ] although they
played those recordings in the courtroom
and they said there was a
dry eye in the house yeah they played
we're like you know on TV they only
played like a few seconds in a few
seconds that's you know I mean and that
was all that you know but if that's
enough it's like I'm sure that I have to
admit I didn't look I mean I know kind
of what the content of the tape is and
I'm sure you could probably find it
because it's the Internet there's a
terrible place yeah but I did not I
don't you don't want to see that but
we're gonna talk about them on the
second half
first half we're gonna talk about Fred
and rosemary West yeah scumbags cuz like
I said yeah and I think I said this on
our last Valentine's Day show too when
we did killer couples before there is
something very fascinating to me I mean
yeah I'm fascinated by true crime in
general but there's something very
fascinating to me about couples that
kill together because it's just such a
weird like dynamic in the case of those
two she was worse than he was in the
West case that you guys seem like
courting according to surviving victims
they said they weren't really scared and
they're scared her although generally
and I think this is true of Brady and
Hensley too is that the male halves of
the couple committed crimes before they
met their soulmate I guess is a [ __ ]
up way of putting it yeah so there is
some argument over whether say Myra
Hindley or whether rosemary West would
have committed crimes on her own had she
you know had they not met these
successes maybe because they did [ __ ]
with before they met yeah I think that I
think the girls needed somebody to tell
him it was all right to do it
that's a feel like I don't think they
would have done it on their try not know
somebody do a fire mop and egg him on
not saying that they weren't messed up
people clearly they were and like I said
in the case of Fred and rosemary West a
lot of the escaped victims said that she
was way worse than he was yeah in terms
of just being cruel cruel shitty I mean
he's probably trying to impress him but
she was into that [ __ ] Tuesday we even
with her little boys and stuff but we'll
get to that yeah it's just like a [ __ ]
up situation but like I said so if you
hate valentines day and then you've come
- yeah
I actually kind of like Valentine's Day
it's like it's go it's all red and take
it's nice and everything like that and
this will be held what number of
Valentine's Day will be for us eight
will be seven someone that yeah seven or
eight yeah I might have to get you a
card I know Valentine's Day today we're
just recording this for Valentine's Day
that is yet to come
well plus it's yeah it's like no it's
like an last show austere Damas we're
doing the future yeah
but also the past yeah I think this show
is actually gonna go up on the 12th so
it will be a couple days before
Valentine's Day but so what yeah that's
what we're gonna do on this show other
than that we're just gonna do like
regular little shout outs yeah my book
is out go yeah whoops very well thank
you very much you guys will enjoy it
audiobooks just flying yeah both of them
and also check out our last movie review
which big man Japan yeah alright so like
I said we're gonna talk about um Brady
and Hindley probably gotta give a
shout-out though what are you doing oh
that's right that's right
okay so sorry sir sorry those of you
know that you know what I'm here doing
the show a half the time I'm drinking
and I I drink it I drink a drink that
I've invented called Kukulcan because
it's tequila of various types you know
I'm mostly it's silver tequila mixed
with guava juice and pineapple well I
was getting it from this Welch's
pre-made blend but I have discovered
something that's even better it's these
guys right here
petite guava nectar that's coming but
yeah it's from citizens from El Salvador
and it'll be like right along the Goya
products stuff here in the United States
it's not expensive about a dollar fifty
this alone with any to any type of
tequila to your preference is good you
could be one in one two parts juice 1
part tequila or you could back it around
two parts tequila one part juice it's
good and you
and to with this you can also reproduce
to replicate my Welch's version of
kukulcan which is one part tequila one
part this and one part just pineapple
juice like dole or libby whatever and
that's about that's about what Kukulcan
is supposed to taste like if it's too
fruity for you just bump up the tequila
until you like it but yeah keep your eye
out for that yes we got it publics got
it at Publix I know you guys like if
you're in the north of the United States
or the country don't know public suits
gets the southern version chain but I'm
assuming that most regular grocery
stores the public at Publix has it
probably yeah the places have it too
yeah Boyet probably sells a similar
version too you know they do actually
and I think it's even called the same
yeah you might be able to get that in
Europe another day there's a British guy
asking me you know how to make that and
that's you know that came to mind when I
saw that yeah some people don't know
much about guava in Brazil we call it
guayaba yeah and it says guayaba on
there too so I guess it's the same in
Spanish baba yeah it's a good fruit yeah
so so if you ever want to know how to
make cocoa yeah like I said when I make
the shirt I'll make the little it's just
like I said one one can go with Silver
Tequila Reposado
and also gold it goes with them all now
it may vary to certain brands I really
like that um what do you call it
Hornitos represented with that juice
although you could probably put Cuervo
gold and margaritaville gold you know
but I think if you if you don't want
that tequila flavor if you want it to be
more mild kind of like a vodka type
drink go with the silver silver tequila
blends with it well cuz I was gonna say
we might have mentioned this on the show
before but we get a lot of our liquor
well we get most of our liquor at Sam's
yeah cuz that [ __ ] is cheapest [ __ ] yeah
it's like I get this big big huge huge
bottle of vodka and it's like 14 $14 and
when you taste it that's great goose yes
sky yeah and he gets the members marks
at that same brand big old thing a damn
percent of Gavi Silver Tequila and I
really can't tell it apart from Cuervo
how much that's only 20 25 to 20 bucks
it's ten dollars cheaper than then
Cuervo silver yeah but yeah they're
their brand I can't jump they have
regular brands to bow we usually just
get their store brands cuz they're good
except for the whiskey
oh yeah it's not good we have got their
store brand whiskey and that was really
not good in fact it's still in there and
for liquor it will last that long in our
house you know that's not good because I
haven't got desperate enough to drink it
they try to sell you a scotch but it's a
scotch whiskey but it's blended and you
know that you know Scott's supposed to
be single malt and you can taste have an
artificial wood flavor to it tasty she's
licking the bottom of our grill not good
that's the first time I drank it yeah I
was like this is like I stuck my face
like in our grill that we haven't
cleaned for several months although I've
noticed that Johnny Walker red and red
label and black label are not as good as
they were 20 years ago
yeah probably them like I said I think
they're making more of it I think it's a
blended whiskey now yeah Glenfiddich is
still real good yeah that's yeah we got
to get on to the show yeah I know that's
like not a thing that's more at st.
Patrick's Day thing I guess all right so
first let's talk about Fred and rosemary
West yeah now there are several
documentaries about these two there's
one called house of horrors which is
actually quite good kind of going around
but these two [ __ ] are again
dammit explain everything explains to
you when you're looking looking Fred
West kind of remind me of the Son of Sam
a little bit an older version of suneson
yeah and a lot like that same car count
[ __ ] up hair and it same [ __ ] do you
hear something weird it's like every
time I saw him do you know who I don't
know if you know
this is but he reminded me of Mac Davis
maybe it was the hair like the singer
from the 70s that had kind of that okay
cut it it's kind of like a white boy
afro sort of a brillo pad type action he
had going it's just he just looks like a
dumpy yeah they trash you don't be
looking people kind of yeah and you know
as we get into this family dynamic I
mean this is and the times have a lot to
do with it - this the trails that they
wore were super seventies ish yeah
because they were seven they didn't
really get caught for the murders until
the 90s yeah but they've been doing it
for yeah and a lot of the pictures you
see a man it kind of dated clothing yeah
like I said they were very like frumpy
and weird-looking it's never it's it's
funny because we always say like people
maybe stretch it back in the 80s like
people that look like Goths and stuff
and people look like punk rockers they'd
be like oh they said they're terrible
people and stuff I'm like no no this is
all the normal-looking people that are
like you got a watch people that look
like us it's like all of our weird shits
on the outside there isn't a weird [ __ ]
inside we do it girl whew look they're
just looking yuppie as hell yuppie as
hell
totally normal real real but you know
exactly what I'm talking about that
chick was giving hand jobs and turning
tricks and [ __ ] on the sly nobody knew I
mean I mean is it's like people probably
think all kind of freaky [ __ ] about us
yeah maybe not nowadays but it's like
we're like this ya know you never
would've known yeah you never would
enough that's the case running ads and
running ads in this paper and hiring
bodyguards to go work the out of the
hotels could be it why because she
needed the money it's just that simple
just needed the money
yeah all right so these two this
actually happen in the West Midlands and
these two are classed as serial rapists
and serial killers because they did both
rape and kill people that they know of
and so you know did torture all that
kind of stuff um so let's talk a little
bit about Fred West first like before
because like I said he had committed
some [ __ ] before he even
her um so he's actually from a town
called much Merkel which I love British
town names you guys it's like I used to
live over there for a while it's like I
just love there's this funny [ __ ]
town names they have now according to
some accounts like other family members
according to some of Fred's accounts the
family that he came from was pretty
[ __ ] up evidently his dad was engaging
in incest with the sisters and that was
like something that you did you broken
the daughters that was something that
dads did I guess at least according to
them yeah Fred also allegedly was
introduced to bestiality by his dad I
didn't know that uh you know I'm not
sure how true that is but that is you
know one rumor that is IQs like what
kind of beast a what are you talking
about it just said bestiality I imagine
I was trying to use my can't imagine it
if you don't tell me specifically what
species we're talking about right I was
talking like what now who I would
imagine in that part of the country it's
probably sheep okay and you know yeah
hey so I'll go down and knock down that
she but here's how you do it yeah when
you see it all make a lot more sense but
okay go ahead he different he definitely
does look like he looks like somebody
looks like a sheep [ __ ]
um there are also allegations that
Fred's mom was also molesting him was
molesting Fred he had a bunch of
siblings I think yeah there's six of
them so uh you know so I don't know but
there was there was that whole [ __ ] up
[ __ ] now although there was all this
sexual abuse apparently going on Fred
and his mother were evidently had a very
close relationship like he was um he was
kind of a dummy and he had he had like a
pretty low IQ he was functionally
illiterate but he said he would go to
school and he wasn't very good he was a
good artist and he could do like
woodwork he
type stuff like hands stuck with his
hands but he couldn't really read and he
was kind of dumb in other ways so
whenever he would get in trouble at
school like his big and his mom was like
super obese and she would like come down
at school like yell at the teachers
really for um you know messing with her
little kid or whatever what they doing I
well I guess when he got bad grades
stuff like that she was one of those
kind of moms like Backman like she was
supposedly like really protective and
she would come like thundering into the
school and like yellow write stuff so um
he only stayed in school till he was
fifteen and like I said when he left he
could barely read he went off to be a
farm laborer um I also kind of not a bit
not a great looking kid but he did kind
of get a little bit better looking later
on when he was a teenager now when he
was 17 years old he bought a motorcycle
and almost immediately got into an
accident crushed his skull broke his arm
and broke one of his legs I think one of
his legs was shorter than the other like
pretty much his entire life
I think after the motorcycle accident
was in a coma for about a week and he
had a metal plate in his head and stuff
like that and they said that his
behavior kind of changed of course yeah
yeah like he started having like rage
issues and things of that nature well
you got a really crushing a skull pretty
bad they put a plate in your head yeah
yeah yeah and it should be noted too
that two years later he got another head
injury allegedly when he was at a
nightclub and he was um real grabby with
girls he would go to club because he
thought that's just what she did well
doesn't everybody do that he just goes
up and grabs their tits or like sticks
their his hand up their skirts and stuff
like that yeah well he was in a
nightclub and he was out on a fire
escape with this girl and he stuck his
hand up her skirt and she punched him
and like knocked him down the fire ski
suit he fell off the fire Satan fell on
his head I was like hey good for her and
busted up his head again so that was
another head injury so we're talking
about a family in which rape incest
stuff like that was seen as no big deal
and also to major head injuries also
like I said he wasn't the brightest bulb
to start with so this is a natural
disaster just waiting - yes we're
happening actually it is happening and
it did happen not sadly enough right so
and when he was about 19 years old he
actually his first conviction that I
know of and that was for molesting a 13
year old girl he actually got off with
that for medical issues cuz the doctor
said oh he's had all these head injuries
and he has epileptic fits now so he
actually kind of got away with it
although his family kind of disowned him
even though I don't feel like they've
probably weren't much better right he
actually got a manual job doing
construction but then got fired because
he first stealing so like I said he was
a criminal pretty much from the get-go
like from what from being a teenager
even before he met his wife so he goes
back to his family finally were like
okay you can come back now so he comes
back and he's about 21 he get he hooks
up with this woman named Katherine
Costello who's called Brina Brina now he
did marry her she was allegedly a
prostitute she had been a petty thief
and a prostitute they had dated before
and then had broken up and whatnot but
they got married later on now when they
got married she was already pregnant
with another man's child and this man
was Pakistani and what happened was when
the baby was born they would explain
well because Raina was got in trouble
with her family because of the
mixed-race baby so they told her parents
that the baby that she was pregnant with
died and that this one they had now was
adopted so because she looked half asian
or whatever it's like you know what I
mean so that was kind of [ __ ] up the
little girl's name was Charmaine that's
what they named her now they at this
point he bought that story I guess they
bought that story I don't know I don't
know like how they didn't live in the
same town so I guess they just kind of
like yeah that's what
whatever so yeah now at this stage they
moved to Scotland and Reena started
getting disillusioned with the marriage
because of Fred's weird like sexual
proclivities he was very sexually
aggressive he really liked you know
sadomasochism he was all into that kind
of stuff and she just kind of wasn't
having it
however they did have a child of their
own at one point named Ann Marie or Anna
Marie and Fred got a job as an ice cream
truck driver allegedly this kind of
allowed him to go and molest kids willy
nilly you know so there was that whole
thing going on now he did that for a
while until he accidentally ran over a
four year old kid with his ice cream
truck dan now I think the kid died now
it was an accident like a judge ruled
that it wasn't his fault
right but he still couldn't be an ice
cream truck driver in that town anymore
because everyone said hey you're the guy
that ran over that kid that's not cool
so then they had to move away so at this
point it's him the kid the wife and then
a friend of the wife whose name was Anna
McFaul and they had a nanny whose name
was icy MacNeil and so all of them moved
to Gloucestershire now at this point the
wife Rina she's like [ __ ] this [ __ ] and
she left but she left the kids with him
and the friend so they're all like
living together in this Caravan or like
we would say a trailer but over there
they said Kerrigan so then he starts
[ __ ] the friend Anna McFaul Anna
McFaul gets pregnant with his kid this
dude had so many [ __ ] kids I don't
even know you don't even know he had so
many kids with everything yeah it's like
if it moved he would have a kid with it
yeah he would impregnate it you know
then boy that's a reproductive strategy
from hell and yeah he's getting away
with it
spreading his seed I feel so did darks I
know I feel so bad because it's like
I've seen pictures of you know his
remaining surviving children that are
grown up
and stuff like that and it's like I
would hate to be them they've had their
names changed right yeah but um yeah so
he gets Anna McFaul pregnant and then
because she was kind of like well why
don't you divorce the first life waif
and marry me and blah blah blah and he
said nah and he killed her
damn so he killed her dismembered her
buried I think she was eight months
pregnant at the time so like I said
nobody knew about this until much later
on but they know that that's probably
what happened and what are you doing the
body did here was it um he usually
generally what he would do is he would
cut them up and like bury them in the
yard and then he would like put paving
stones over them or he would like being
buried them under paving stones or then
like build things over them like wells
or whatever so he did that kind of [ __ ]
she was never reported missing evidently
yeah no one reported her missing at the
time and like I said they didn't even
know about her being dead until much
later so um the first like person that
he wasn't you know that he wasn't known
to that wasn't part of his family in
other words that they think that he
might have killed was a 15 year old girl
named Mary bast home and she actually
disappeared from a bus stop and she was
reported missing obviously and they
never found her but they're suspecting
that that was something that he did also
um so at this point he's kind of like
you know still stealing and he fence
stuff from his job and everything like
that then he gets a job as a bakery
truck driver and this is where he meets
rosemary whose name was rosemary let's
at the time now she was quite a bit
younger than him but I think but I
believe she was only 15 when he saw her
at a bus stop or whatever and they kind
of started up a relationship she also
had quite a [ __ ] up childhood her dad
was a paranoid schizophrenic and what a
severe disciplinarian her mother Daisy
had actually had depression and they did
electroshock therapy
on her while she was pregnant with
rosemary which they think may have
contributed also rosemary was also
allegedly sexually abused by her father
and she was one of these kids she um she
was also not extremely intelligent she
was a little chubby when she was a kid
so she got teased a lot but she was very
aggressive like her dad always kind of
told her so go you need to stand up for
yourself cuz I mean he used to beat on
her and he used to beat on the wife and
everything you need to stand up for
yourself don't let anybody pick on you
so when she was in school and somebody
would pick on her she would knock him
the [ __ ] out you know what I mean
so she was um you know not like a shy
retiring girl even back then even though
like I said she came from a very [ __ ]
up family situation and because she was
kind of heavy and because of her
aggressive nature she boys her age
didn't really like her so she became
very promiscuous and started sleeping
with a lot of older men so there was
that whole [ __ ] going on too and she was
also raped by someone else later on um
finally her mother couldn't take it
anymore and took rosemary and second
they went and lived with I believe it
was a raspberry sister who was older and
married so they went off on that now
when they when rosemary met Fred West
hears cats move yeah she's moving the
camera a little camera kitty
don't move it she the camera - yeah okay
you gotta get her she's like all right
now ironically when Fred and rosemary
started dating Rosemary's dad did not
approve of Fred it was like I'm you know
I'm just sewing you if you don't stop
seeing and stuff like that even though
he had been beating on her and raping
her and stuff on the go but somehow this
was a step too far I don't know the
competition that's that's kind of
actually
what I was thinking of so during this
time period
rosemary got pregnant they had a
daughter named Heather Fred was kind of
in and out of jail for like petty [ __ ]
you know it's mostly like theft and not
paying fines for previous crap and
everything like that
now while he was in jail like he was in
jail for like nine months one year
Charmaine
who was the daughter from Fred's first
wife you know what I mean she had boy
dia killed when he killed no okay that
was never that was the girlfriend right
yeah yeah yeah this you're gonna lose
track because no this was Charmaine the
little girl that when he married Reena
Costello she had already been pregnant
okay with the Pakistani man yeah this
was that kid right that they that Fred
and Reena were raising as their own kid
and we're saying that it was adopted
Rama blah now while Fred was in jail
Charmaine was like living with rosemary
staying with rosemary and they're pretty
sure that rosemary killed that little
girl yeah while he was in prison now
this this was one of the things because
you know when they later got arrested
fred was like trying to protect her the
whole time if she didn't know and you
know she didn't do anything and you know
leave her alone and stuff like that and
for a long time they were like well they
didn't have any solid evidence that she
had actually killed anyone although they
did think that she had participated in
the sexual abuse but was that little
girl when they kill her um I'm not
really sure she was pretty she was
pretty young okay so just about four or
five six yeah well I'm not gonna say
because I'm not entirely sure but um
okay but yeah but when they later on
when they found you know that when they
did analysis of the skull and her teeth
and stuff like that so they could
determine if she was killed in the time
period when Fred was in jail then they
assumed that rosemary had done it so
they found the body yeah she was one of
the ones that was found but that was
later like I said okay
so all right so Fred and rosemary got
married in January of 1972 now pretty
much as soon as they got married Fred's
like well you need to work as a
prostitute I'm gonna set up a little
room for you and you can have clients
and it'll be extra money and I can watch
yeah that's and she seemed to be like
totally fine with this situation so he
would also take like naked photographs
of her and send them into swinger
magazines like for ads so people were
coming over the house and actually in
one of the I don't remember if it was
house of horrors but if it was or if it
was one of the other documentaries but
they actually found some of the videos
that he had had that he had made of her
with like some of the other clients like
coming into the house and I'm just like
this is the skeevy [ __ ] I've ever it's
like oh my god who's like so [ __ ]
nasty
but there was so there was all that kind
of [ __ ] going on and so the more kids
they're having you know because they had
another daughter then named May in 1972
and then they decided well we need a
bigger house so they moved to the very
famous 25 Cromwell Street which was the
address that where they were caught and
that's kind of where most people that's
the address that most people associate
with them now they had a couple of
renters that lived upstairs you know so
they for extra money and stuff but they
they put like a stove and [ __ ] upstairs
so no one would come down and like
disturb them because they have all this
stuff going on so Fred made a very
special room for rosemary that had peep
holes all in it and cameras it also had
a little red light helpfully on the
outside so that when she was in there
entertaining yeah you know none of the
kids would go in there some mommy's
working damn so yeah there was that
whole thing um as the years went on she
had seven more children three of which
were fathered by Fred the other ones
were fathered by various clients so yeah
they were all mixed-race sell different
races and whatnot
so there was that whole thing going on
now later that year in about October of
1972 Fred and rosemary hired a nanny
caroline owens now they just kind of
found her like at a bus stop or walker
hitchhiking or whatever the hell she was
doing and said hey um you know do you
need a job we need somebody to look
after all these [ __ ] children that we
love and she was like okay cuz she
needed money now when she started
working there and she started living
there with them both of them started
making sexual advances toward her to
which she was like no thank you
you know what I mean but so so after
that she kept refusing them but then
actually at one point they got
frustrated with her and they like
knocked her out and tied her up and so
and I think they might have drugged her
too and then they were like threatening
her like we're gonna let all our friends
come over and [ __ ] you and yeah all this
other kind of [ __ ] and then then he said
then I'll kill you and I'll bury you
under the patio or whatever so she just
kind of went along with it
now they did let her go and she's
actually there's an interview with her
on the on one of the documentaries and
it's like pretty frankly she was she was
worse than him yeah she was one of the
ones that said that because like I said
every now and then they would let
somebody go but this she was like the
most famous case they did let her go and
she went to the police but when the
police investigated Fred was able to
convince them that it had all been
consensual so all he was given was a
fine yeah we're like fifty pounds
so that's nice yeah I don't know how
that happened yeah so yeah I'm not sure
what was his word and her word against
the girl so they were able to overpower
yeah that's yeah because you know they
just said what would anybody really
believe like how [ __ ] up like
especially if it was just a man believed
outlandish but a man and his wife like
doing that
to you because she said both of them
raped her right you know and she said
though she was the woman copyright
thought it was - outland
that's what I mean they thought it was
too weird and they're like yeah that
doesn't happen yes so now over the
subsequent six years it is thought that
they murdered at least eight other young
women usually same type of thing where
they would find somebody to bus stop or
they would find somebody hitchhiking
they would pick them up and go hey and
we need somebody as a nanny like a
live-in nanny for all our kids bring
them back to the house proceeded to put
them down in the basement tie them up
torture them you know sexually assault
them and it got worse and worse like as
a time like they did worse and worse
[ __ ] to them yeah you had like a torture
chamber set pretty much an interview
with the son the son said when he was a
little kid he walks down to the basement
and interrupted his dad torturing one of
those girls yeah and he can kind of
remember it yeah and he just said he'd
said you turn around and go back
upstairs you didn't see anything - have
a deal yeah and I was under the
impression based upon what the son had
said is that he was skinning her alive
that he had her hanging out from the
ceiling was skinning her alive that's
that's because like I said by the time
they found the bodies he most of them
were nails on one of the well one thing
that he would do was he would take the
fingers off like at the joint okay that
was like one of his signature taking the
fingers mutilations okay yeah what was
he doing with pliers or something I yeah
I guess and I'm not sure why he did it I
don't know why like because he thought
that they wouldn't be able to identify
the fingerprints or or if that was just
like his thing like doing this Linda
Myers
but yeah so there was a lot of the
bodies that they found a long time since
I've heard his tests yet I was under the
impression that he had that he had
skinned her alive and something to do
with her fingers like you said yeah cut
her fingers off or yeah yeah but yeah so
the ones that that kind of went missing
were murdered during this time period
one was named Linda Goff she was
actually
a friend of theirs she's like a
seamstress or something like that so
they ended up killing her the next one
was Carol Ann Cooper she was just
walking home from a movie theater one
night and they lured her into the car
you know stuffed her into the car or
whatever there was another woman named
Lucy Partington also disappeared from a
bus stop while on her way home from
Christmas they actually held her captive
for a week before killing her so then
there were between 1974 and 1979 five
more victims
these were Theresa Seigenthaler Shirley
Hubbard Juanita Mott Shirley Ann
Robinson and Alison chambers so those
are the ones that they know of that
they're assuming that there are probably
more these are mostly ones whose bodies
were later found um what she's turned it
up yeah what are you doing kidding yeah
so not only was all this horrific [ __ ]
going on but Fred was also sexually
abusing one of his daughters Anna Marie
who was one of his daughters with Rena I
think yeah she actually got pregnant
with his child but it did she ended up
losing it because it was ectopic so they
had to do an abortion um now she took
off she went and lived with her she ran
away from home and went and moved in
with her boyfriend now after that
happened Fred started abusing the other
daughter Heather now this there are some
they're not sure the paternity of
Heather they're not sure if this was
Fred and Rosemary's daughter or cuz this
is [ __ ] up too check this [ __ ] out
remember how Rosemary's dad was like so
dead set against you not going out with
Fred and stuff like that well a couple
years later on like after they got
married and they've been living together
and she was working as a prostitute out
of this house
her dad would come over and have sex
with her and like pay and Fred would
watch so there is some speculation that
Heather was actually the product of
rosemary and heard
weird you know what it means so I'm not
really sure they think that you might
say this is like a family of wild
animals but not even wild animals that's
what they meet it's like not even
anymore that bad this one animals are a
lot more noble actually yeah this is
like Damon's yeah a family of Damon's
yeah yeah so fred is like abusing
Heather he's also abusing the daughter
may and what he would do it's like I
said he would bury them in the yard and
he pretended like he was doing home
improvements all the time like oh I'm
gonna build this nice well or patio and
stuff but he was putting [ __ ] bodies
under there only nobody knew until later
on so in 1986 they actually almost got
caught because what ended up happening
was that Heather was at school and told
some of her school friends kind of what
was going on the house or like the abuse
that she was going through and one of
her friend's parents called the cops so
after that happened Fred and rosemary
killed Heather yeah and put her under
the patio yeah under patio stairs I
think and then later on they would
threaten the other kids with if hey if
you ever tell anybody what we did we're
gonna put you under the patio like
Heather yeah they don't tell them yeah
they would tell them that kind of [ __ ]
like I don't think any of them saw it
happened but a bunch of them said that
that they would say that to them all the
time so so this has been going on since
the [ __ ] 1970s now they didn't get
caught until 1992 in 1992 Fred made a
videotape of himself raping one of his
daughters yeah she told her friends
about it the friend's parents reported
the West's to the police um you know it
was funny is that the younger children
the dars actually you have seen
interviews of them they're quite normal
they knew that all this [ __ ] was weird
yeah you know most kids do no it's like
that's why they were trying to get the
hell out of there yeah these kids they
knew that these parents were evil we're
[ __ ] up yeah it's like you would know
because like I said this is an abnormal
yeah even if you were raised in that
situation you know that's not right you
know that's not right yeah well they had
friends who lived normal lives they knew
that all right and I guess the older
ones would tell the younger ones this
ain't right
yeah crazy yeah so at this stage the
cops finally go and there was one
investigating officer her name is hazel
savage and she's like oh I remember this
Fred West guy because she was
remembering some [ __ ] that happened with
his first wife Rina Costello and she's
like what ever happened to that woman
it's like you know no one's heard from
her or anything like that so they
wondered where she was so another girl
later came forward and said that Fred
had raped her as well so at this point
the police were able to get a search
warrant and they started searching the
house at this point they were just
looking for evidence of child abuse
so they start you know searching the
house and the grounds Fred got arrested
for rape and sodomy of a minor Rose also
got arrested as his accomplice so while
they were going through the system all
their children were taken away
thankfully and you know put in care yeah
so at this so fred is in jail rosemary
attempts suicide
unfortunately her son saves her cuz
that's actually she's still alive I
think yeah she's still alive to this day
Fred's not but that so while they before
they were put on trial like the victims
that were going to testify against them
backed out I mean there were just little
they were just like 13 years old
cheering up your work that's it's okay
people you should see what the hell's
going on back here she's fine the laptop
she's like what and then she looks up
and I was like I don't understand why
you're like yelling yeah I'm just
playing with the paper she was to play
it there she loves paper she loves to
eat it so I'm just kind of letting her
Duke's if I take it away she'll just
like stir like a bunch of noise out
she'll make a bunch of doors and
everything she makes a lot of noise yeah
it's not like a cat she's more like a
monkey yeah like a monkey in a puppy
yeah Oh in one like in a little cat form
yeah but yeah she's so if that's what
that noise is
okay yeah so so the victims like didn't
want to testify like I said there were
only like kids they were just like 13 or
something like that so they got scared
and they backed out
however one of the investigating offers
officers was still kind of like you know
there's just too much sketchy [ __ ] going
around this family and like there's all
these people that are kind of missing
and we don't know where they went to so
she kind of kept pursuing them and then
they start interviewing the other
children and this is when the kids
started saying hey they kept you know
saying that they're gonna bury us under
the patio like Heather blah blah blah so
at this point they said okay we need to
dig up this whole [ __ ] yard so they
dig up the patio and they find at first
they find two sets of human remains they
know one of them is probably Heather
they also found the bodies of an McFaul
you know what did the woman that he was
having sex with earlier before he met
rosemary and Charmaine the little girl
that the that rosemary probably killed
so they found all of those bodies and at
this point you know they they just kept
turning up more and more human bones I
think at that particular house I think
they found 9 sets of remains and then
went back to the house that he had lived
in before and found I think three more
sets of remains so he's been doing this
for quite a long time
nobody fest up for a little Charmaine
well see when Fred West was taken into
custody he finally confessed to the
murders he was trying to protect
rosemary I think but later on when they
examined Charmaine and we're trying to
determine like they were trying to close
in like on a you know on a death date so
they could see if it had happened when
he was in jail and they determined that
it was very very likely that she was
killed while he was in jail which means
that it was probably rosemary did it
because that's who she was motive was
just to get rid of the burden financial
burden yeah right I mean neither of
these [ __ ] gave a single [ __ ] right
yeah about anybody yeah and it just
seemed like they were they kept having
here they were remember seeing like
little interviews with Fred and I don't
think he had a real concept of what rape
was anyway I think he thought just sex
was like that yours did
he did say almost exactly that did he
okay when they asked him yeah cuz I've
heard him talking and stuff like that I
think the way he was brought up and he
was you know his brain was kind of
messed up and everything like that
when people you know when he was asked
about rape he said well doesn't everyone
do that right yeah so I don't think he
had any yes you jumped on somebody
because you liked him they fought you
and then just overpowered and that's
just how it was like I was doing that
and finish not that yeah approach
because that was that was how he learned
how to do it there in his family yeah
that's how it went down and his family
and that's that's just that was his
version of the birds and the bees
yeah and it's instructive to that even
though he eventually did confess to the
murders he would not confess to raping
anyone because he said no all these
people wanted to have sex right yeah so
he had some issues with consent right
yes um because like a he would he would
not he would confess to what he could
say if he wanted it then there was
consent right that just means it doesn't
matter if she wanted it or not that's
just how it goes
sorry sorry ladies this just the way it
works yeah he was consented yeah yeah
but he actually did end up like I said
he he insisted forever that rosemary did
not have anything to do with the blah
blah now weirdly like rosemary as soon
as he got arrested and he was like
trying to you know take her hand at the
inquest or whatever and she blew him off
and that [ __ ] him up like a lot and he
actually he was on suicide watch for
that for a little while but then they
kind of it went a little lacs later on
and he hung himself yeah and he actually
left a [ __ ] note listen to this [ __ ]
I never very long no he didn't even I
don't even think he was like convicted
even he was a [ __ ] he's kind of like
that other guy that kept those girls
trapped in his household the old Miguel
what was his name
the guy you know the guy who is here in
Florida has kept his girls trapped in
his house Castro Ariel Castro as soon as
he can keep a woman captive for dem
eight ten years yeah no problem
but then they send him to prison he
couldn't even Heddy kurz killed himself
what a [ __ ] and that's the reason it's
like that it just makes me so mad like
they're willing to subject other people
here to this horrible torture but then
you do like a mild version version and
they start crying but yes so he hung
himself listen to this [ __ ] suicide
note because this just about made me
throw up two rows west Steve and May
which was you know to it there are there
kids well Rose it's your birthday on the
29th of November 1994 and you'll be 41
and still beautiful and still lovely and
I love you we will always be in love the
most wonderful thing in my life was when
I met you our love is special to us so
love keep your promises to me you know
what they are we are put together
forever and ever is up to you we loved
Heather both of us even though they
killed her
I would love Charmaine to be with
Heather and Rina so I guess he meant
buried yeah you will always be mrs. West
all over the world that is important to
me and you I haven't got you a present
but all I have is my life I will give it
to you my darling when you already come
to me I will be waiting for you commit
he hanged himself with bedsheets you
know now like I said so he kind of
escaped justice a lot of us were kind of
upset about that as I said initially
rosemary was only convicted or was only
suspected of rapes and things like that
but when they figured out like when
Charmaine was killed they figured that
they could accuse her for at least that
murder so she was actually found guilty
of 10 murders ended up being guilty of
10 murders put in prison in 1995 and she
was given a whole life tariff meaning
she will never be let out although she
has insisted to this very day and like I
said she is still alive that she is
innocent and she has never wavered from
that
certian even though there is a lot of
evidence saying otherwise but like I
said she's never gonna get out and she's
even like taken up with she had a
girlfriend for a while
she might still have I don't know I
think that worked in the prison system
or something like that but so that was
that kind of whole thing going on but
she was just constantly constantly
trying to get her conviction overturned
and she's like I'm not gonna be like
Myra Hindley who we're gonna talk about
next never get out yeah she said I'm not
gonna be like Myra Hindley I'm not gonna
die in prison and blah blah I'm like
yeah you probably are on the up side all
the kids got freed and they live they
live normal the ones that got murdered
yeah the ones who got for ya you were on
the they did the talk show rounds and
everything yeah yeah and like I said if
you if you want to see some of the you
know documentaries about them stuff like
that it's actually I mean it's
nauseating but it's actually really
interesting and like you said the kids
actually did grow up and they seemed
very normal and I'm like well thank [ __ ]
for that and like you said they knew
that it wasn't right yeah they knew it
was right even back then and you know
they got the [ __ ] out they evidently
kind of stood up for each other yeah you
know I mean trying to help each other
out of there the older ones were trying
to we're warning the younger ones you
know I'm getting out of here you guys
need yeah
and I mean hopefully they're doing all
right
cuz man yep see you guys if you could if
you put that in a movie people would not
believe it I mean now they would because
they know about these two [ __ ]
but yeah if you put that movie before
that and people like nah as bad [ __ ]
that can't happen but it did yeah super
fun happy Valentine's Day everybody
yeah This Is England - yeah I'm talking
about the ozarks er yeah I would almost
expect it more from like then just like
you know these mouths don't
yeah that movie like disturb me so much
I was okay like Cornette baby I was just
like oh my god it's just it bothered me
so much alright so let's take a break
right now when we come back we're going
to talk about the very famous Moors
Murders yeah perpetrated by Ian
and Myra Hindley another bar killer
couples for our Valentine's Day special
UK edition yeah so we're gonna be back
in just a couple of minutes okay
everybody Ginny's got some new shirt
designs up four of them really good ones
to Atlanta Ripper who put Bella in the
which out the HH Holmes murder castle
and of course demon child cuz man said
he could these are updated designs I
think they look really cool Jenny did a
great job
bottom where they found making Jenny
they were very fun and thank you very
much I think they came out ready yeah it
really good they're very high quality
shirts Jenny and I we're sure our own
shirts at certain times when we're
trying to put spotlight on ourselves and
you can put a spotlight on yourselves if
you go ahead and pick up on these shirts
today you guys are gonna love them mix
in the description WWL com at 13 o'clock
yeah so go check out our store at wwl
com / 13 o'clock we got these four cool
new t-shirt designs plus all our old
ones if you'd rather get one of the old
ones but these ones are awesome and you
should check them out they're also
available in women's cut they look
really cute JT's got some so thank you
go check them out
the faceless villain a collection of the
eeriest unsolved murders of the 20th
century vol 2 includes cases spanning
the years from 1960 through 1979
featuring such infamous crimes as the
triple homicide at Lake Bodom the family
massacre known as the good heart murders
the serial killings of the Zodiac Bible
John Jack the stripper and the freeway
phantom the slaughter of dozens of women
and girls along the highway of tears and
the Texas killing fields and the
mysterious death of suspected spy the is
doll woman along with dozens of other
fascinating and horrifying accounts by
it now from Amazon in print Kindle or
audiobook format
okay so this is our second couple yes
this is our second couple on our UK
edition of our Valentine's Day special
about killer couples
I should note too that I forgot to
mention that like I said the very famous
quote unquote house of horrors where
Fred and rosemary West lived in
Gloucestershire was actually demolished
in 1996 and they not only demolished the
house they smashed every little piece of
it so that no one would like you know
take any souvenirs or anything like
that's they just like [ __ ] salted the
earth right yes that's how they felt
about that kind of [ __ ] so it's gone
there's a sponge it from reality that's
what I mean I've actually been to
Gloucester I had a friend that lived
there many years ago and he told me
where that house was it's not there
anymore like I said all right so now
we're gonna talk about Ian Brady and
Myra Hindley yeah two winners better
known as the Moors murderers now I
should say that I got actually
interested in this case in the 1980s
because I was a big Smith's fan still am
actually yeah and on their first album
there is a song called suffer little
children and in a biography of the
Smiths that I read he said well
Morrissey had read a book called beyond
belief by Emily Williams which I have
right here I actually bought it at a
library for a dollar because it was out
of print at the time and this is about
the Moors Murders and there's a chapter
in here called suffer little children
and that's what he was writing about so
I got kind of intrigued with it so I
looked it up because it seemed like
something that a lot of Americans didn't
know about so that's kind of what got me
interested in I read the book and I read
a bunch of stuff about it so this
actually took place in the 1960s and
again this is a fascinating case to me
any kind of any killer couple is
fascinating to make us just the the fact
of like two people meeting in this
horrible you know confluence of factors
it's like hey I met this other person
and like suddenly we're gonna kill
people together that's just like super
[ __ ] up yeah when you see them they're
like two mob kids yeah which yeah they
kind of work yeah so let's talk a little
bit about Ian Brady he was actually born
Ian Stewart
and he was born in a slum in Glasgow and
he his mom was a waitress in a tea room
his father is unknown now when he was
little his mom couldn't really afford to
take care of him so she did kind of like
half-assed it wasn't even an adoption
she just like knew a couple and we're
like hey you want a kid look after him
so they did this couple named John and
Mary Sloane so you know she would still
come and visit and she didn't like
abandon them or anything but she just
couldn't can't take care of me
right so she would come and visit back
and forth and everything like that now
he seemed like I'm kind of a messed up
kid from the beginning
unlike Fred who seemed like was okay of
kind of a dummy until he got all these
head injuries
Ian seemed more like a sociopath type
kid there was a lot of allegations that
he tortured animals when he was growing
up
they said he was actually above average
intelligence but didn't really apply
himself like he wasn't a very good
student he was very introverted you know
[ __ ] like that he also later on he
started developing kind of a weird
unhealthy interest in you know Nazi
atrocities you know he was super into
war - he's super into Marquis de Sade
Nietzsche he'd like read all this kind
of stuff and he started to develop this
attitude that he was like superior to
everyone else like he kind of had that
sort of thing going on he was you know
so he was reading all that kind of crap
and again when he was a teenager he
started committing like petty crimes he
broke into people's houses burglary
things like that so he spent time in and
out of like juvenile halls and whatnot
now while he was a little bit later on
he actually his mom had remarried to
someone named Patrick Brady who was a
stepdad and he went and moved back in
with them and took his stepdads last
name I guess in some way to try and make
a family I guess or trying to make it
seem like he was part of the family I
don't know but he took the stepdads last
name later on now while he was in jail
or juvenile hall for one of these you
know minor offenses he actually learned
bookkeeping and accounting and stuff
like that and ended up getting a job as
a stock clerk at a place called no words
merchandising and this is where he met
Myra Hindley now Myra was also from a
pretty working-class background she was
from Manchester specifically a little
part of Manchester called Gorton um her
childhood was a little she seemed more
like a normal girl
her dad did physically abuse her much
like rosemary West she was actually kind
of an aggressive girl when she was
bullied she would you know knock your
ass out so you know same kind of
personality type there um she actually
when she had a younger sister named
Maureen and when Maureen was born she
got sent off shipped off to live with
the grandma although she said she didn't
mind but she was actually pretty smart
she was like a decent student she was
good at sports and stuff like that
didn't date a lot in school I read
somewhere that that people called her
square ass I guess square arse if you
want to like the British spelling kiss
her genes didn't fit too well because
yeah because she had like really broad
hips or whatever but she you know she
made money like as a babysitter and
stuff like that so I've no one thought
anything unusual she didn't seem like a
strange person now when she was 15 years
old kind of there was kind of a
traumatic incident that she brought up a
lot she was 15 and she had a friend
named Michael Higgins and she was
supposed to go to this local swimming
hole and go swimming with him one day
and she didn't go you know she was kind
of like oh I got something else to do
and he went and he drowned so she kind
of had like really bad like survivor's
guilt because she thought she was a
really good swimmer and she's like if I
had been there I could have saved him
and all this other kind of stuff so she
goes like really traumatic it
traumatized by that type of stuff and
she brought it up a lot and at this
stage she started getting a little more
like rebellious and things like that
like started bleaching her hair white
and all this other kind of stuff now
when she started working as a typist at
the same company as Ian Brady worked at
now she
[Music]
really she kind of loved him from afar
for quite a while before like he even
really noticed her asked her address
what was the age difference she was a
little bit she was no she was 18 and he
was 22 okay okay so he was a little bit
older than I thought it was she was she
was younger right so um you know she had
dated before she had even been been
engaged before even though she was young
but you know working-class long time ago
yeah it was a long time ago and that
wasn't that unusual but then she decided
on and really want to get married bla
bla so she broke it off but she kind of
got obsessed with Ian Brady because I
feel like she saw him as a bad boy um
you know he was very he seemed
intelligent he seemed very intense
he seemed aloof he was kind of stylish
for his income yeah she um so she wrote
a lot about him like in her diary like
she equated him with like James D and
her like Elvis or something like that
like this kind of bad boy type of image
and like I said she wrote a lot about
him she was like totally obsessing for
like a year and kept talking about him
and then finally like a year later they
were at this Christmas party or
something for work and he's like oh you
know finally asked her out now I heard
that their first date was going to see
the movie the judgment at Nuremburg yes
romance that sounds like something that
sounds like something he would do
because like I said pretty much
immediately like once they started
dating he was all teaching her
quote/unquote about Nazis and about all
his philosophy and about marquis de sade
and trying to sort of indoctrinate her I
guess with his ideas it's like oh well
technically if you look at it a certain
way like murder and rape isn't really
wrong and like all this other kind of
crap you know what I mean he was that
kind of dude he also seemed like she
seemed to change a lot to please him you
know she was had already been bleaching
her hair but she's like kept doing that
she started dressing like sexier and
more stylish more mod looking
and everything like that if you see
pictures of her from the time she does
look very mod and stylish kind of
glamorous he actually sounds like one of
the Callum Bond shooters like yeah
that's who he reminds his name's Terrace
yeah he sounds like one of those guys
they were into that they were in a kfdm
but yeah National Socialism but mostly
you know it's just just more about style
over substance most of it and you know
it's easy to take Nietzsche and read
yourself into what Nietzsche is saying
yeah she's been abused for you know
almost a hundred years you can read
yourself and you read yourself into what
Nietzsche is saying he's now talking
about you you're a loser I feel like
okay I feel like this is an issue like
there's a lot of dudes of this type and
this is very like Ian Brady's
personality seems very much to me like a
lot of the kind of mass shooter type
personalities and that kind of thing
where it's somebody that's not they're
not like a super genius but they're like
above average advantage they're
intelligent enough to think that they're
smarter than everyone else but they're
not smart enough to know that they're
not smarter than yes and they're also
not smart enough or they're also not old
enough or accomplished enough to have
true power because they don't have any
true accomplishments yet
yeah they're early in their history a
lot of them yeah so you know you can't
go around being the [ __ ] Nietzsche
and uber-bitch 19 and you're working on
the minimum wage job and yeah you don't
even have a car
Nietzsche and teenage boys that [ __ ]
doesn't make sense
yeah well because GG was not talking
about yeah well the problems it like a
lot of teenage boys and a lot of teenage
girls too you know they think they're
smarter than ever they know everything
and it's like you can't tell them [ __ ]
because they already think I'm immortal
and I know every
and it's like you're seriously you're
not and I know like all old people say
that to you but they're saying it to you
because it's true not just to be mean
there's something about being wise
yeah see all T all of us have gone
through almost four teenagers we
remember feeling like that and now we
feel really really dumb and say well
yeah educates you in a very different
way over time they'll say you become
great when you realize you ain't [ __ ]
that's part exactly when you realize you
ain't [ __ ] that's when you start having
a chance yeah yeah that's I think that's
a good way to put it like don't don't
[ __ ] on yourself like oh yeah you suck
and you're the worst I wouldn't get no
it's you just have to understand that
you're not special
yeah you're not special that's all and
you have to kind of like you know kind
of struggle and get what you want you
know the way everything imposes on
everything else yeah really and you
might think you might think that you can
impose your will on other people but
there are a lot of other people that can
impose their will on you and they will
namely the police yeah okay the police
in the judicial system can impose its
will over you bigger than a [ __ ]
you know why they got guns I got guns
and you can kill one of them and it
means nothing you'll just keep swarming
you they'll send ten thousand after you
no matter so doesn't matter get over
yourself yeah and maybe that's that's
good advice for everyone really get over
here ya know what the kind of power to
each he was talking about is he talking
about state power I really had a lot to
do with what they were talking yeah
you're talking about guys like you know
literally to talk about guys kinda like
Adolf Hitler really yeah okay
and others he wasn't a there's a lot of
guys like that so like I said yeah Ian
Brady definitely seemed like that kind
of dude he was all he's um you know she
would come over to his house he always
had German wine he was always like
lecturing her about Nazis and about
Nietzsche and about Mark II the German
wasps yeah yeah it's like let's go on a
date sure got [ __ ] on California why yes
you're a German wine is not something
anybody ever towards me brags fine Carol
yeah yeah Italian wines German beer sure
yeah you know but okay so um also she
had actually been brought up a Catholic
and was actually fairly religious but
the longer she hung out with him the
more she kind of went in an atheistic
direction because he s he was telling
her she was a dummy for believing in God
or whatever um and at this stage I think
that her family and her friends and
stuff starts to notice a change in her
like I said she started to dress more
glamorous more stylish she started
getting real surly she started like
keeping secrets from them like not
telling him where she was going and [ __ ]
like that um they also think at this
point that Ian Brady wanted to see how
much power he had over her so the first
thing that he supposedly did was he was
like well we're gonna do like a bank
robbery or a big bank heist or something
like that so you need to like set that
up he wanted to see if she would do it
you know just go rent a van go do this
that the other thing and she did it
without questioning him and at this
stage he's like okay well now I know
that that's you know that I have a power
over something like that like I said
allegedly now after that you know after
this incident where she seemed to go
along with his plans for criminality
without really questioning him then he
starts talking about how he wants to
commit the perfect murder and so this is
where things start going off the rails
yeah this is kind of a weird fantasy I'm
going to commit the perfect murder yeah
and another thing too that pisses me off
it's gonna it's gonna involve a teenage
girl yeah well these two this
[ __ ] I would I think the perfect
murder would involve millions of dollars
also you would think you would think
that well it shows you house how low
this guy's standards are you know yeah
I'm gonna kill some cute girl it's gonna
be perfect
well in little kids little kids it was
that's right I forgot yeah yeah yeah
that's right
oh I mean their first victim was a 16
year old girl but although I've heard
because what they would do is he would
ride his motorcycle like behind the van
that Myra was driving like they would
rent a van and she would drive it and he
would ride on the motorcycle behind her
and they would ride around looking for a
victim and he said well I'll flash my
headlight at you when I see somebody
that I want you to stop and pick up
because she was his you know she was the
hook she's a woman she's in the van by
herself you know no one would think
anything of it and actually this was
like a pretty small town a lot of people
knew her so it's not like she was a
complete stranger being a motorcycle man
myself
I bet she was a PSA PSA or a triumph
something like that probably little
tiger you know single cylinder okay yeah
I don't know trying to think of a
British motorcycle from the time yeah
yeah so I've heard that the first time
they went out to find the first victim
that he flashed the light at her when he
saw like a young girl like why she was
like eight or something like that and
Myra said didn't stop and then he kind
of yelled her like why didn't you stop I
told you to stop and she said no I know
that little girl you know so we have to
look for somebody else and I've heard
that I don't know if that's entirely
true or not but this particular night
which was July 12th 1963 they did
eventually find a victim and this was 16
year old Pauline Reade now she was
walking to a dance like in the area so
Hindley comes up to her and says hey you
know can you come help me this is
usually how she would do it she say hey
can you help help me look for a glove
that I lost or you know can you help me
with these packages or something like
that like I said you know people knew
her around town she'd been babysitting
and stuff like that so it wasn't all
that weird so they would get in the van
so they pick up Pauline Reade and then
they drive to Saddleworth Moor which is
kind of a remote area outside of town
there at which point Ian took the girl
raped her and strangled her and buried
her on the moor
now there is some controversy about
whether Myra was present Myra says that
she just sat in the van even though she
knew what was going on but she said but
yeah but Ian Brady later said no she was
there and she helped in the sexual
assault helped facilitate it so like I
said Myron has always denied you know oh
I was always somewhere else you know
yeah in this case I always wondered what
the [ __ ] does she get out of this I mean
you see that's what makes me wonder
about this kind of stuff it's like why
and you know later I'll get into a
little bit later on because you know she
she said a lot of [ __ ] later on like
before she died about how he was forcing
her into this kind of stuff but he said
well I don't buy that um but I'm not
saying that he wasn't a shitheel and
that he might have coerced her but we
did the worst her yeah she definitely
did seem so like obsessed with him that
she would basically do anything he asked
yeah I think it was I think that's
essentially what it was he was just
trying and then she was trying to like
impress him it's like shows look how
badass I am I'll help you murder people
right yeah I definitely think so I don't
I think it was kind of like a sign of
allegiance and loyalty to the guy yeah I
think that's exactly what it was was
ever for me I think that's exactly she'd
be his Igor his hinge man yeah I think
she thought that it was like bringing
them closer together like it was some
kind of like weird and Ian Brady said
that - he said I think she saw it like
little marriage ceremonies like it was
like bonding that but what's weird is
like baby proved to me how much he loved
me by letting me screw this other woman
that's some weird [ __ ] man yeah it's
like what a normal person a normal
person if some dude said that to me like
I said I should call the cop you in the
face I wasn't blame I wouldn't shoot you
I meant okay I might shoot you in the
kneecaps I mean I ever had you do some
[ __ ] like that you you [ __ ] call the
cops okay thanks I will never [ __ ] I
know you wouldn't you
but like I said if you did I might not
shoot you in the face but I might
minicabs that's [ __ ] sick [ __ ] yeah
that's messed up yeah um so yeah just
for the record yeah so yeah Pauline
Reade sixteen years old was their first
victim four months later that member
twenty third nineteen sixty three their
next victim was a twelve year old little
boy named John Kilbride he was in a
market like shopping in a market in a
place called Ashton underlined and was
kidnapped from their same type of thing
where Myra came up to say hey can you
help me unpack these boxes or can you
help me like find this glove or whatever
and then kidnapped taken to the more
where Ian Brady apparently raped him
strangled him and buried him right there
you know the boys is bisexual yeah yeah
yeah cuz yeah like I said but three of
the victims were male and two were
female right
then came June 16th 1964
I think Marvin was watching I think she
was - like I said she denied it later
but I don't he did that for her yeah
yeah their next victim was also a twelve
year old boy named Keith Bennett he was
walking to his grandmother's house in
June of 1964 as I said um so same kind
of thing she lures him into the van and
then raped strangled and buried on the
moor the next one and this is the kind
of the famous one because of the very
famous audio tape was a ten year old
girl Leslie and Downey and this happened
on Boxing Day which is December 26th
1964 she was actually at a local
fairground she was standing by a ride
and Myra came up to her and realized
that her parents weren't around so she
was kind of like hey why don't you come
and help me with this stuff and
everything in the little girl was like
okay you know and then she went along
with her and this little girl they
actually took her back to their house
and tying her up and raped her and
tortured her over several hours and they
recorded it yeah I heard someone like an
audio recording it is the most horrible
and I've only heard like bits of it you
just don't listen and they I think they
played it was I think it was 16 minutes
or something like that and I think they
played the whole thing in court I heard
that [ __ ] and I wanted to set them to on
fire most people did I was set him on
fire yeah Christmas turn Oh on there
what they did to that girl was [ __ ]
man yeah she was just like begging and
so just like it was horrible I can't
understand and they took photos they
took pictures of her yeah and you were
like doing Kylie Polaroids they were
doing kind of like an inquisition on her
like it was like a kind of like a
Gestapo interrogation yeah it was that
girl just wanted to go home and I got
Tara what Tara yeah blood Carly yeah
that's a good way of putting it yeah
now thank you mad makes you really mad
yeah well you can see why because that
everybody in the courtroom had to hear
that
you can see the whole mean the reaction
that people had to those two and
particularly because he died much later
than her she died pretty early that [ __ ]
right there it just goes to show you how
immoral it is not to have a death
penalty because there are some people
out there that need a sister [ __ ]
killed and it's weird because the death
penalty over there had just been ever
turned like before they were caught like
very shortly before they were caught and
you know this lethal injection that's
too weak you know they need to be hung
by the neck until they're dead like he
did in the Old West they'd even drop
them they just look at hangin like that
I mean some people I'm generally against
it for just minor [ __ ] but some people
like this kind of stuff yeah Ince and in
some ways I think the death penalty is
too good for them well you see I said
hanging her from the neck until they're
dead like the 1800s that's traditional
for our
country here he doesn't mean but really
if it was up to me if I was making the
rules for [ __ ] like this I would have
done what the ancient Greeks did at
least one of the ancient I would have
given them what was called the bronze
bull oh yeah we're going to put him in a
bull and you put a fire underneath him
yeah you know roast I'm alive you pretty
much man yeah that's that's what these
two because that would probably take a
while take a long time and like I said
this is very very few people like
deserve that but if anybody does if
anybody does these two days yeah for
that for a homicide like that yeah so
yes so those were their victims now
their last victim was the one that
actually got them caught because they'd
been getting away with this up to this
point now their last victim was a guy
named Edward Evans and he was actually
17 apparently I'm not sure why they
decided on him in particular I think
they just went to a bus station and
picked him up you know I think there was
some there was something where Ian or or
the Myers brother-in-law David Smith
said something about let's go roll a
queer or something like that so they go
and pick up this guy Edward Evans they
bring him back to the house and so
they're talking to him now David Smith
who was Mira's sister's husband
Myra had like I said a younger sister
named Maureen and she had married this
guy David Smith David Smith was at the
house and Ian gets into an argument with
this Edward Evans person and basically
starts beating him with the blunt side
of an axe and then like strangles him
now David Smith sees this whole thing
so he's like obviously upset about it
but he's like also scared
I mean before this he had been kind of
like he looked up to Ian Brady probably
for the same reasons that Myra Hindley
did they thought he was cool I guess but
when he saw this he was like horrified
so then he was afraid that they would
kill him as well so he helped them like
kind of clean up the area I was like
yeah I totally won't tell anybody but
then he went home told my resister
Maureen holy [ __ ] they just killed
somebody and then they went
the cops yeah yes so that whole thing
happened so new who else this guy
reminds me of his that's your [ __ ]
Charles Starkweather a little bit yeah
yeah yeah so yeah so at this point like
the cops did immediately believe them so
they go to Ian Brady and Myra Hindley's
house and they find Edward Evans his
body is still there it was like wrapped
up in a [ __ ] blanket and it's in like
Ian's bedroom or something like that now
initially when police came to the house
and found Edward Evans body
Ian Brady says okay well me and David
Smith and Edward Evans we all got in a
big fight and it got out of hand
Byron doesn't have anything to do with
it so Myra actually didn't get arrested
with the rest of until four days later
until they were searching her car and
they found like a document in there
which said like where she had written
down like they were planning the murders
and they like that she's not like
criminal masterminds or anything like
that
now it also came to pass that Brady had
blabbed to David Smith and he's like oh
I've killed other people too we buried
them unsaddle worth more now here's the
[ __ ] up [ __ ] is that there are
pictures because they used to you know
Ian and Myra used to go hang out on this
more like he would take pictures of her
and they'd think that some of the
pictures that he took of her are over
the graves of the people that they
killed like he's like hey stand there
for the where we buried that kid and
I'll take a picture isn't that cool or
whatever so you know after David Smith
told the police that they said okay well
we need to go start digging on
Saddleworth Moor so they start digging
because they obviously had all these
missing children cases in the area that
they were beginning to link to these two
[ __ ] the body of Leslie and Downey
was found first on October 10th 1965 11
days later they found the body of 12
year old John killbride so at this stage
they're like okay well we found the
bodies there was missing children this
like yes he killed this teenage guy in
his house like supposedly after an
argument
but there wasn't any solid evidence like
tying them to the murders of these two
kids that they had found however when
they searched the house more thoroughly
they found like a ticket for a you know
when you go to a train station and you
check your luggage do you put it in a
locker okay they found one of those and
they went to Manchester Central Station
and they found the locker and inside the
locker was a suitcase and inside the
suitcase were the pictures of Lesley and
Downey and the audio tape that they'd
made of her it was in this suitcase so
at this point they knew that these two
were the [ __ ] that had killed them so
they were still deny deny deny they were
not guilty not guilty they're still
trying to pin everything on David Smith
they said oh well yeah Lesley and Danny
was at our house but we let her go alive
so David Smith must have chased her and
killed her later on it's nothing police
were like yeah tell us Yeah right so
right so the two of them are brought to
trial in April of 1966 pled not guilty
to all charges and the media is like
having a [ __ ] field day they're like
you know it's funny because the British
tabloids even British regular newspapers
are much meaner than American ones and
it's like they'll say all kind of
horrible [ __ ] about it see they'll call
you a monster like right to your face
not much you can do about it but yes so
this it was like a big deal it was like
[ __ ] packed to the rafters so trial
actually did not last that long May 1966
Ian Brady was found guilty of the
murders of Leslie and Danny John
killbride and Edward Evans Hindley was
found guilty of the murders of Leslie
and Downey and Edward Evans also she was
found guilty of harboring Ian Brady even
after she knew that he had committed a
murder so that was another charge
against her too because they hadn't
found the other bodies yet and Brady and
Hindley had not confessed to them then
they weren't charged with the other ones
yet so but they both got 30 years which
were later made into a whole life tariff
like I said so they would never get
out later on in the 1980s they actually
ended up finding Pauline the but their
first victim they found that body
however sadly Keith Bennett the body has
never been found and the sad thing is if
I saw a documentary about these about
the Moors Murders and his mother kept
she kept writing to them too they were
in prison asking please you know where
is my son and myra actually went out to
the moors a couple of times with the
police and was trying to find them
that's how they found Pauline's body but
they never did find keith Bennett's
body and unfortunately his mother passed
away before they found they still have
not found his well she tried to find it
but she couldn't figure out where it was
yeah yeah there wasn't any markers and
Ian the thing about it is that I was
listening to an investigator on the case
that had actually talked to both of them
like extensively and was like the thing
about Ian was that he was real difficult
like he would always be like oh well
yeah I'll help you by showing you the
bodies but you know you have to do this
for me and blah blah blah
they're like Myra was much more helpful
like you know they said okay I'll show
you where the bodies were and they did
actually find one you know when she went
out there but you know he just seemed
like what are you gonna do for me and
then I'll tell you where what you know
what I mean like a [ __ ] sociopath to
me that the case sounds a lot like the
Starkweather case it does yeah it's very
similar I would say character wise he's
kind of like was him was this Harris
from the Columbine shooters yeah Patrick
Harris I think everything was Dylan
Klebold and the other one was his first
name and clay ball if I remember
correctly he was the one he was just
kind of all over the place jittery yeah
the other one was kind of more
rationalist kind of sounds like him yeah
you know Ian yeah but still although I
would say this is is that Harris
wouldn't have gone after little kids
like that though it was a sexual motive
they were just angry at the school
yeah and you know I've mentioned before
or not in other episodes that I knew
some people that went to that school and
grew up and they said that was a [ __ ]
school well in a way it's like I'm not
condoning it but that's more
understandable to me because especially
if you're bullied and picked on and
stuff I can see like snapping and kill
I'll bet you that Columbine was a yuppie
yuppie school with a bunch of yuppie
heavy parents and if you didn't fit in
with the yuppie culture then you they
just treated you like [ __ ] yeah but this
kind of [ __ ] where you just cuz [ __ ]
here call for ya just picking up little
random children and it did [ __ ] man
don't take my words out of context if
they're treating you like [ __ ] school
doesn't mean shoot it up you know don't
do that
wait obviously you're gonna get out in a
couple of years what the [ __ ] you
thinking that's what I mean it's like my
school does not mean anything in the
grand scheme of things yes it sucks high
school wait dad ow
yeah high school just sucked for me well
except for my last year I had fun that
year but you know up until then it sucks
but all right so I understand that
feeling but it's like in the greater
scheme of things it's not gonna mean
anything in a couple years you won't
even [ __ ] remember it believe me I
only had only my freshman year kind of
sucked in Michigan actually I was a
sophomore they say my junior High's
doctor high school is okay rest the time
I loved it when I was a soft when I was
a junior and a senior chef it was a prom
keyword prompt oh poor thing
yes he's like super popular I was super
buff I was and I was like a weirdo goth
chick I hung out with I was a weirdo guy
with all the punk rockers I was a
bleacher smoking it [ __ ] I was gonna
drama though I was in trance so I was in
chorus do a lot of musicals and knew all
the cool girls and they ended up being
celebrities Marilyn rice cook you know
she was from 24 she's Mike's girlfriend
she made it yeah and no see who else
that I know Parker Posey
ya know so it was just a different time
you know but I was a misfit that [ __ ]
became popular yeah yeah yeah and all
the jocks [ __ ] want to hang out man
[ __ ] well there was kind of like there
was kind of this you know there I was
you know they were alpha males and I was
like a Sigma yeah yeah yeah and the
Sigma is like an alpha
gone wrong but yeah so both of them like
Myra goes to prison Ian was actually
sent to Ashworth psychiatric hospital
for the criminally insane he actually
tried several times to starve himself to
death like he would go on hunger strikes
and things of that nature essentially
and I read this they're like if if it's
in prison and a prisoner goes on hunger
strike they're just like okay [ __ ] you
starve to death you know I mean over
there but if you're in a psychiatric
hospital and you're starving to death
has to do with your mental illness which
in this case it did then they're like
okay well we have to force-feed you
because you have a mental illness
so they actually force-fed him and he
was like he was trying to like sue
essentially to get the government to
allow him to starve himself to death you
know what I mean um like I said later on
Myra kind of came out and tried to say
that he had forced her to do all this
stuff that he would rape her and beat
her and threatened to kill her family
I'm not sure how true any of that is or
if she's just trying if she was just
trying to you know not not seem like
such a [ __ ] because as much as Ian
Brady seemed like the instigator in all
this for whatever reason the British
public hated Myra Hindley with the heat
of a thousand suns like more than hurt
more than him that's because she was the
wish she was the she's a girl and she
was supposed to know better I kind of
that's what I feel like it is because I
was like well what he did was probably
much worse and it's like if they had not
met she probably wasn't Ector of
children right a nurturer I think that's
exactly what he was supposed to return
him in and report him yeah you know I
think that's exactly so there's much
that was much more hatred I feel like
there was much more hatred directed at
her than there was at him not that there
wasn't hatred directed to him because
there was you know what I
when they're arrests anytime they were
like transported anywhere like the huge
bobs and they well they're just growing
here they're just considering him to be
a maniac yeah he's supposed to be this
girl who could have stopped it like I
said I was thinking about this earlier I
was thinking about because remember I
think I mentioned this on a previous
show that what 85% of serial killers are
men and 90% of murderers just one-off
murderers or men so it's almost like if
a man murder somebody no one is
surprised yeah but when a woman does it
it's like a big huge deal because it
doesn't really happen that often it's
like you're not supposed to do that
you're supposed to be you know I mean so
I think that's probably the case she's
supposed to be better than they said she
was she's supposed to be better than
that and she wasn't so you know that's
why all the hatred against her like I
said um she actually ended up dying
quite a bit before him she died at the
age of 60 in 2002 a bronchial pneumonia
like I said right before she died she
turned in all these papers where she had
written this big long like
autobiographical thing like talking
about you know how he had forced her
into and she wasn't even there most of
the time like she was in the van or she
was in the bathroom where she's lying
yeah that's what I mean I I'm kind of
not buying it I don't think anybody else
did either because Ian Brady as shitty
as he was he's like no she was there she
was in on the whole thing she was into
it too um so which is far more likely I
think that's a lot more likely because
it did seem I read some of the papers
that she had I don't think they've been
published in their entirety but it did
seem like oh you were always in the
kitchen or you were always on the other
side of the ridge like when the show's
going down you're not in I'm not in on
this Myra you're hiding your averting
your eyes you don't want to be there for
all this but you sure as hell don't rat
him out yeah it's like she could have
gone to the yeah if you felt that way
you would have gone to the cops I mean
what really I think yeah I'm afraid of
him which maybe she was but as a
spectator yeah I was getting a thrill
out of it I think she I do feel like
that like I said I'm not saying
basically she got live snuff porn yeah
I'm not saying like I think that if she
hadn't met him she probably would have
just been a normal person but I think
that she had a particular proclivity
yeah and he pressed those buttons yeah
like a particular personality type that
was like you know it was susceptible to
that type of thing that type of
manipulation so when she met him there
was like a horrible like a synergy he's
showing her this stuff she's reacting to
it with [ __ ] emotions and then like
she gets kind of like she gets into that
yeah yeah the thrill of it and maybe she
then all of a sudden she feels closer to
him because yeah he trusted her so now
you know she's it's like a psycho
relationship tighter than marriage yeah
cuz they have dirt on one another yeah
basically and that's he actually came
out I mean like I said as much of a [ __ ]
stick as he is he did seem pretty
articulate about the reasons that she
stayed around well she was that's pretty
much a sense yeah what girl said now
that she's in on this he's not going
anywhere
yeah so now they can yeah because like
hey if you break up with yeah I'm just
gonna tell on you can't break up with me
that's what she's thinking yeah that
kind of thing she did seem and like I
said when she hooked up was a she's very
young she was only 18 and she like I
said she had obsessed about him from
afar for like a year before that's old
enough to know better though that is old
enough to know better
you definitely should like I said a
second some dude Schama girls just
telling you second since I was like hey
I'm gonna go let's pick up a girl I'm
gonna go raper over here go to the cops
you just shoot that or go to the cops
yeah you shoot it then you're gonna end
up in court then bury him somewhere
don't say nothing to nobody
yeah yeah just drop him in a lake
somewhere this with a rocked out of
their ankle but did this don't say
anything his show should you know this
show should be an example of a joke I'm
just kidding the criminal justice system
no matter what country kind of dick tend
to get it wrong they have a tendency to
get it wrong if you if the dude was
gonna go out murder some girl you're his
date and you shoot him in the face and
then call the cops he was gonna go
murder some girls what'd you do
to shoot him that's exactly what they
would say like yeah I got it did though
Mindy charged you with first-degree
murder second-degree murder yeah you
spend the rest of your life in prison
don't [ __ ] do this
don't play the games like I said unless
your she heard that you're not gonna get
caught
women now go to the cops if you can yeah
although they might not believe you
that's kind of like but but at least try
at least try um yeah so she died in 2002
like I said the British newspapers when
she died very large headlines had rot in
hell which I thought was very nice Brady
didn't die until 2017 Wow he was 79
years old still oh man apparently he has
written an autobiography but I don't
think it's been because they said the
stipulation has to be he's you know he
has to be dead before they can publish
it I don't think they've published it
yet actually um I know this is [ __ ] up
but I'm actually kind of curious to read
it maybe maybe it'll just make me mad I
don't think there's much there although
I have to say like we've been watching
you know when we recorded this Netflix
just put up the the Ted Bundy tapes you
know the new series boats head Bundy and
you know it's a lot of [ __ ] that he said
like in interviews with a with a
journalist back in back in the day like
in 1980 or whatever and I don't know I
just find them fascinating because I'm
like what in a way they're they're the
way they think is like so alien to me
that I'm just kind of interested in like
what angle they're coming from so in
that sense I'd be kind of interested to
read it a lot of it was lies although I
think I'd be more interested to read her
account because I want to hear her
excuses as to what it wouldn't it
wouldn't probably read too well because
she was doing this at the age of 18 yeah
after decades in prison okay and missing
so much development and so much time
passing by and the information that she
would give you would be really distorted
yeah because you know I mean you're
dealing with like a 60 something year
old woman that really hadn't lived a
real life past 18 yeah she's just in
this institution
and she's gonna be telling you the way
she felt long time ago
yeah culture that's long gone I don't
even remember anything from when I was
18 right so I don't remember how I felt
she's telling you about memories of
memories of memories yeah out of
tottered context you've probably been
reconstructed right without without a
modern context because they don't live
in the modern world they're incarcerated
into a prison that's almost unchanging
yeah it's like that same culture you
know so you wouldn't learn much from it
she'd just be basically lying whether or
not she knew she was lying or not yeah
you know I'm talking about and that
can't deliver accurate information to
you and that's something that like I
said one of the investigators on the
case that had spoken with both of them
extensively that was saying the [ __ ]
about you know Ian Brady was very
difficult and he would only help you if
he thought he was gonna get something
out of it he said Myra was actually a
lot more helpful but he did say that she
was also highly intelligent and very
manipulative he did say that about her
so and they'd be talking about something
that happened in the 60s yeah the world
has changed a lot since that was a long
time you know guys
but yeah so like I said this case is
always fascinating me and this is
actually I don't know if this is
probably still it was at a print when I
bought it but that was like a long time
ago the book beyond belief it's actually
it's strange because it's kind of it's
written in a sort of Mancunian patois
which if you're not really familiar with
that area like it might be kind of a
hard read because you know to me and
it's it's almost kind of written in a
dialect um but yeah I guess because he's
from there too so he was like you know
it was something that happened local
today's area the author but trying to
figure out trying to figure out the
motivations of serial killers from a
long time ago is very difficult it is
yeah I mean you might even from nowadays
right I mean imagine trying to trying to
dissect Albert Fish I mean all our fish
is created by that dude is mystifying
today and he was created by forces from
the 1800s he is created by societal
forces that nan younger exist true
people like that or not
created anymore because the society you
need to create those doesn't exist
anymore
yeah so asking him why he did certain
things from a modern point of view
you're never really gonna understand it
because you don't really understand the
world that they came from because you're
yeah they're a large part of the context
is gone it's gone right yeah that's what
I'm trying to say so you have a much
easier time trying to understand a
serial killer from our time yeah yeah
cuz one thing that I do context has a
lot to do with it yeah because I'm gonna
say it's like I'm not saying that some
people aren't born messed up or bad like
many they are yeah but there has to be a
particular push and pull between a
person that's born with a particular
mental proclivity and the environment
that grow up in and I think I've
mentioned this before
even if someone is born kind of messed
up or with a proclivity toward being a
serial killer let's say but they grow up
in a normal home they have normal and so
in that way they might not have gone
down that road whereas if they had grown
up say in an abusive household then they
might have I think it has to be two
factors I don't think maybe maybe in
very rare cases no matter what how the
kid was brought up maybe they would just
be [ __ ] up and I'm sure that happens
in a very small percentage but I think
most of the time you need both both of
those factors working in tandem
I think consider this remember that show
we did a few months back about the guys
in the 1800's ever the two brothers that
were going on captured the heart
brothers a heart brothers yeah you can
look look at what the Hart brothers did
you go man those [ __ ] were
nasty I mean you know that got like some
badass serial killers today but a lot of
what they did in their time back in the
1800s all right wasn't that bad there
was a lot like what the Apache did yeah
it wasn't actually captured people and
enslaved them and captured women and
made them slaves and kill people and cut
their heads off and scalp people and
sure you know they did so when you look
at us to know others are are you talking
about serial killers you just trucked
i'ma try
warriors what are we talking about yeah
you'd have to be there and really
understand the context although the fact
that we remember them means that they
probably went a little over the top well
they were definitely nuts but yeah
people of the time when they said well
those two just went engine because that
was a term and not it was a term that
they did back then which maybe that's
what happened maybe they were hanging
out with some pretty aggressive tribal
warriors and they just kind of adopted
those ways or like you know it let's
just do it the way they do it yeah we're
gonna capture women and kill men and
make people are slaves and sex machine
out of Conan yeah basically yeah like I
said it's it wouldn't have been remarked
upon as much back then I guess cuz a lot
of people were doing horrible [ __ ] yeah
because the world was a [ __ ] up place
back then yeah but you take that
situation and you put it into a suburban
setting in the nineteen no one's gonna
be looks very different yeah and you did
that nowadays yeah holy [ __ ] that's
right it would print out the [ __ ] FBI
and the [ __ ] yeah so it to take you
out yeah we don't put up with that [ __ ]
anymore yeah that's good though I that's
good it that makes me feel better
because at least for a little more
[ __ ] civilized yeah than that that's
pretty it bothers me that you know back
in the day
Rebecca you do that [ __ ] you had to do a
lot of it before people would even
comment on it back in those days there
was no legal infrastructure or no
societal structure to violate they were
just existing in the wild yeah basically
you know and that was a survival
strategy steel yeah you know stealing
was a survivalist like some machine out
of Mad Max that's what you're talking
about I was gonna say - when we were
talking about Brady and Hindley and when
we were saying that a lot of people
harbored a lot more hatred toward Myra
because she was a woman I think it
helped too that it was you know not
helped but you know what I mean because
it was the 60s and still very rigid
gender roles it's like you know woman
suspected the yours but you're expected
to like grow up have kids you know be a
mother and everything like that and she
subverted that role by killing Joe
rather than raising them and I think I'm
not saying that that wouldn't play the
same now but I think it was probably
more you know since since gender roles
were a lot more concrete back then maybe
are more rigid I think there was a lot
more hatred toward her but like I said
it people hated her so much every time
she came up for release there would be
huge like right it's like in the [ __ ]
stir like people would be on the street
saying don't let her out don't let her
on they never did I don't think gender
roles had much to do it much to do with
it you're looking at it from a moderate
Sensibility I think what it was is the
sensibilities over time was just that he
was the bad guy you were you were the
good guy you know I mean or the victim
you should have told people yeah
basically they didn't realize I don't
think they realized that she was an
offender yes that she was getting off on
that
yeah well I'm like but that does kind of
relate to gender roles because I think
that people didn't realize that women
could get up on that kind of [ __ ] up
okay that's what I meant well maybe
that's okay because you know and like
you said we were talking when we were
talking about Fred and rosemary West and
that was a little bit later that was in
the 70s but I think that people didn't
take some of their victims that escaped
seriously at first because they're like
you know if you had gone to somebody in
the 60s or 70s and said there was a man
and his wife and they both raped me and
she was into it too like I think a lot
of people would be weird enough I than
I'd be like that sounds ridiculous
because they didn't think women were
like that yes we're quite as shocking
because when you look at the West
you saw garbage they were like white
trash there were garbage people and they
yeah they say looks like they would do
some bad [ __ ] they seemed very like just
these dim yeah yeah kind of this couple
here actually looks kind of style she
had nice cool [ __ ] hair and they were
trying to dress up they didn't look like
they didn't look like dirt bags
I mean they were but they didn't look
like dirt bag so the West definitely did
yeah alright so
let's wrap up our Valentine's Day
special hopefully we haven't boned you
out too much for Valentine's Day so we
got two days you can like do some fun
[ __ ] buy some chocolate get some roses
have a drink do some [ __ ] even if you're
by yourself are you are you alright I
know I'm not doing good he's not doing
well happy Valentine's Day to you this
is my little baby right here
weird please don't ask me to kill any
children ha ha ha ha I had a tie back to
the thing sometime so anyway I hope you
guys enjoyed our Valentine's Day special
well enjoy it is probably not the word
but you know yeah so if you liked the
show remember like share subscribe on
all your social media if you'd like to
financially support the show be greatly
appreciated you can go to our patreon
page patreon.com/lenguin
time donation also check out our last
movie review which was big man Japan you
know also check out our Zazzle store I
promise I'm gonna add some new shirts
eventually I just haven't got around it
making it a bit busy man I'm gonna make
a Google Con one like yeah in honor of
Tom here she's got to finish this audio
book no it's not tomorrow's Tuesday I'm
not gonna tell you what Monday you're
watching it on a Tuesday unless you're
on patreon in which case you aren't
watching it on a Monday it actually
isn't Monday but yeah so check out the
Zazzle store I promise we have like a
bunch of really cool shirts on there now
and glasses and stuff but I'm gonna add
some more in the future
and that will do it for our Valentine's
Day special episode 130 oh and now I
have to say something shocking so you
can whip the glasses up do it do it do
it
that's pretty awesome I feel bad for
everybody that's just like listening to
the audio version and not seeing the
video because they're missing out on
this epic [ __ ] charade I not missing
out on anything I mean some 1950s glass
I like the VA gave me these glasses well
they give them to you like yeah I asked
to give to me yeah I'll get a pair of
new pair of glasses every year I know
these these are yours how are they yeah
oh yeah yeah cuz remember I broke mine
and I could and I couldn't afford to buy
a new one soon I just stole your
couldn't afford to buy new ones we live
in this big old house right here
okay Glen shut it down out of a bathroom
- Eureka yeah yeah he is the water you
man I got a bladder the size of a lime
so everybody have a happy Valentine's
Day trying to get out of here and we
will see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]